we have the story from gbn
eggs to be rationed across UK until
spring 2023 supermarkets including Tesco
Asda and little taking urgent action
uh buy some chickens I like I don't know
if this is going to happen here in the
United States probably not we're a very
very big country we have I think we've
got more Farmland in the UK they're not
they're not as large but the energy
crisis I look I'm bringing up the eggs
thing just to be silly it is a very
serious story but uh with with what's
going on in in Ukraine and Russia the
latest report I saw was that Russia was
pulling back missile batteries and so
there's they're expecting a barrage to
come down like a serious one now like
Russia's not giving up on this and that
just means it's going to get a lot worse
not the midterms are over and Joe Biden
has done dumping strategic petroleum the
prices are going to Skyrocket again and
now we're also hearing this 25 percent
of U.S faces potential winter
electricity outages fuel shortages have
increased risk to U.S power grid
so uh buy some chickens you know just a
couple in the backyard I guess if you
can and uh you know they'll eat the bugs
live in the pot and they'll give you
eggs but uh I would just say right now
we're looking at home prices collapsing
people don't want to buy
interest rates are going to go back up
inflation's getting worse gas prices are
going to Skyrocket the Band-Aid that
they put on the economy to try and save
Democrats in the midterms is now losing
its Effectiveness because abandoned over
a bullet wound can't do much for long so
uh I don't know what do you guys think
well first of all I agree with the
buying chickens things we've got them
over in the UK so I guess we'll be all
right from the egg crisis that's coming
allegedly but yeah um absolutely it was
a Band-Aid as you said and it's it can't
do much for a prolonged period of time
to deal with the really disastrous
effects of the Joe Biden presidency that
were just temporarily ameliorated by
this injection of money and people are
going to feel it and who are they going
to blame because the media will say it's
the it's the Republicans you should have
voted harder you didn't vote hard enough
so I don't know how are people going to
be able to explain that to themselves
and also the Trump presidency from the
lockdowns as well we have to understand
the lockdowns are still having a very
severe effect on our economic way of
life there's even major shortages of
antibiotics that people can't find in
U.S hospitals where children are are
left stranded and screwed over because
they don't have the medicine because the
supply shortages from that lockdown are
still affecting our uh financial markets
today which is absolutely crazy and and
I think think we still haven't seen the
rest of it yet these Financial
consequences of just spending money
giving people two thousand dollar checks
bring them back the inflation reduction
act which doesn't really reduce
inflation but spends more money on
climate and other social justice Warrior
causes that Bill Gates Spurs on uh is
not going to help anyone we have to
understand we're in for some big trouble
and there's no denying it
this is kind of a segue but uh Biden's
80th birthday is Sunday and oh happy
birthday we did not get an annual
physical release this week which I
thought to be extremely annoying I know
that the Biden Administration is not
trustworthy but at least pretend I would
have liked to have seen the report that
inevitably would have declared that he
is competent and healthy and good at
stuff uh because at least then you are
keeping up the premise that you have to
pretend I don't trust the Biden
Administration and
I am now concerned that they aren't even
pretending to hide anything anymore they
are openly not talking about his health
they're not even walking through this
yeah they're not even I think the
emperor has any clothes at this point
it's it's all like well I guess everyone
knows does anyone really well they're
stuck right if they put out a clean bill
Health everyone goes I don't think so
and if they don't they have to admit
that he's not going to run in 2024 and
they're not willing to do that either I
feel like this is such a strange power
grab and I feel sorry for my generation
and basically all Americans out there
who are having to pay the price for this
you know
I'm sad for this country
because we should be teaching our
younger generation how to think
critically and how to survive and we've
not done that and now we have a whole
bunch of you know whiny loser cultists
who are like I have to work eight hours
on Saturday we need a union and it's
like okay dude at this point I'm kind of
just like take your cities you can have
them I'm gonna get away from the cities
move somewhere else and just try and
succeed and I I encourage everyone else
to do the same uh I'm not saying abandon
the political fight quite the opposite
I'm saying make sure you are cleaning
your room before you try to change the
world right and then my attitude is your
worst case scenario if you get in shape
Eat Right Start you know working on
yourself is that if it all comes
crumbling down
then uh you'll be all right you'll be
okay and the hipsters will be like why
can't we get avocado toast anymore and
you'll be like because they're grown in
Mexico in the winter and they ship them
here and now there's no energy because
you're an idiot
you don't want to do any work fine you
don't get your avocados I mean man look
at this Twitter stuff the Twitter melts
up they're like they're like I worked
four hours a week and Elon was and
doesn't want to pay me half a million
dollars and it's like uh-huh and it's
it's you know I've I've said it before
if the American people knew how much
money these like New York media people
were getting paid for as little work as
they're doing there would be a
revolution overnight Working Class
People in this country do not understand
you walk into that Google office these
people are all six figures and they do
nothing there's like they're I'm
watching people like sit there drinking
coffee reading a book I used to go there
and you know I'd be invited because
people I know people at Google I'd be in
their cafeteria I'm like so what is it
these people are doing it's remarkable
to me that when I worked for I worked at
O'Hare I'm lifting 50 000 pounds of
luggage every day for 10 bucks an hour
struggling to make ends meet couldn't
afford it and then when I walked in that
Vice office for the first time I just
started laughing I was like where is
everybody and like I work from home I'm
like what what they published like one
article per week amazing
well that was a work advice one article
a week well they're laying people off
now yeah
that went viral a couple of months ago
was it a week's ago uh no it wasn't
about Twitter it was about LinkedIn yeah
right where the the woman's like here's
a day in the life of a 23 year old
whatever at LinkedIn and she just it all
she seemed to do was sit around and eat
snacks like we were talking about the
journalist yesterday who he was driving
a Ferrari in a five million dollar
mansion Porsche excuse me you got the
difference there come on Lewis what's
going on listen huh
it's still ridiculous and again there
there is so much of of these people that
take so much for granted they're so
entitled and we're so lucky to even be
born in the United States when you we
compare how we live to how the rest of
the world lives there's a big difference
if you travel the world you see see it
and it's shocking it's terrifying and to
see people take advantage of that and to
to see people just not want to work hard
in this situation not take all the
opportunities presented to them is just
mind-boggling to me personally at least
but uh yeah aha I would never want to
build advice ever they're Cod people
yeah they're NPCs like
look
Good Times make weak men
yeah you got a lot of people who are
born into the the the peak of American
gluttony they do no work they never had
to work they never had hardship and now
they're thrust into the world and uh I
mean we weren't look we used to say that
these woke people got out of college
they're in for a rude awakening we were
half right most of them were in for a
rude awakening got really angry and now
are voting to make the world like their
daycare campus but we're also seeing
funny videos of people being like they
scheduled me for eight hours on the
weekend I need a union
that's a great one eight hours on the
weekend Oh Heaven's me wow no I have to
lift a rock to Lewis's Point like both
of my this is horrible I don't know why
we started this but like I mean I know
you have a similar story but both of my
parents are immigrants and I remember
asking my dad once do you ever wish that
you know he had opportunity to move back
and then before they had kids and I
remember asking him like do you ever
wish that I had your accent do you ever
wish I was more in touch with that part
of our culture
um and he was like no we knew it was a
dying country like we left so you would
have opportunities that we did not think
you would have in the UK like that was
more important and I think that that is
a perspective that so many people don't
have like they assume that things will
always continue to get better and better
and when they're faced with challenges
they aren't willing to think critically
about the sacrifices that have been made
for them or that they need to make for
their future yeah Gila is absolutely
right uh there's hilarious there's a
reason people in in Poland literally
have their own jaucus Jaco are called
little plots of land that they have
outside of their major apartment
buildings where they just grow their own
food they also preserve their own food
can their own food and growing up in
Poland it was routine during winter oh
yeah we make reserves and and we have
reserves that we could eat so we don't
have to rely on the Communist
centralized government force that will
give you a piece of paper allowing you a
certain allowance of of bread of meat
that you were given as a ration that
everyone was allowed to have which is
absolutely crazy you would have your own
by being prepared and I think with the
government here becoming more
centralized that's something that more
and more people need to realize that at
the end of the day you are only
responsible for yourself especially when
it comes to the larger crap storm coming
our way that the government is creating
well I feel like you're Leonard's right
you're responsible for yourself but also
you're responsible for your progeny and
your family and your immediate Community
like you choose who you interact with
day today and the impact that you have
on them like don't trust the government
to make things better that's what I
don't understand about people coming out
of college who are just waiting for
someone to fix their problems like
that's never been realistic I don't know
what experience you had in life that
made you feel that way it was crazy when
uh I was working for a company
I I had a uh somebody
fresh out of college first job
and they were telling me I don't know
how to do this task someone needs to
tell me how to do it and my response was
I'll just figure it out and they're like
what do you mean just figure I need to
be told what to do and I was like take
the time to figure out how to operate
the system and then I had to explain to
them I was like
if someone else knew how to do it they
wouldn't have hired you to do it but I
get it in college you have a professor
who tells you how to do things that's
not how it works here you're hired
because nobody knows how to do it and
it's your job to figure it out
surprise surprise these people struggle
yeah and they can't they can't make it
well just I think they're living in a
myth there's something called the wig
interpretation of History they may have
heard of and it does rely on this belief
system that things are always
progressing forward in an upward and
onward Direction so we have more
technology we have more freedom whatever
that is supposed to mean under certain
circumstance but because we have more of
stuff therefore everything else about
Society must be better and it's I think
really bunk I I talk about this too
people are like this is the first
generation where we're worse off than
our parents and I was like I don't know
if that's true because my parents didn't
have cell phones when they were younger
they didn't have access to the summation
of human knowledge they couldn't argue
with strangers and look at pictures of
cats you know For Better or For Worse
and it was even really difficult to get
TVs you know very expensive so
if you wanted to go out Friday night
with you know grab drinks with your
friends like good luck try calling the
phone leaving a message otherwise
nothing so we do have a lot more
luxuries they did they didn't have now
that being said because of these things
good luck getting a job if you don't
have a cell phone
so now it's a necessity you it may be
benefit beneficial to you which means we
may have better things but we we don't
have the excess cash to start families
so you know the things you all end up
owning you thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time